thank you thank you so much
thank you very much this is so nice so
nice of you ladies and gentlemen it has
been a longtime dream of mine that I
would one day receive an honorary Oscar
and tonight I feel I am one step closer
to that dream oh so now it's just the
class head level has dropped simply I
can't possibly express how excited I am
tonight because the Botox is fresh
you know it is said that the art and
craft of filmmaking is collaborative so
to be singled out and rewarded tonight
means that that is not true
is it my imagination or is this year's
Oscar ceremony a little on the cheap
side I must thank the people who spoke
on my behalf tonight my high school
friend Bill Taylor bill by the way he
was a distinguished visual effects
artist and cinematographer whoever
thought we would meet more than 50 years
later on such an auspicious stage
congratulations on your life and career
too bill and following bill following
bill a comedian so renowned and funny
whose work has only grown over the years
and who never fails to make us laugh in
new and unique ways if only we had had
someone like that tonight
you should have seen Marty shorts face
fall what I told him the gift basket was
taxable and then the beautiful speech by
Tom Hanks thank you Tom
everybody loves Tom Hanks what a talent
Tom Hanks Tom Hanks
I saw captain Phillips I didn't think it
was so funny
but seriously I have so many people in
my career to mention and thank my very
first manager back in the 60s bill
McEwan my first two agents Marty Klein
and John Gaines some of you may remember
them John Gaines was all business one
time he called me and he said Steve two
things one hello
carl reiner how lucky was I to get with
Carl Reiner taught me so much about how
to work on a script david picker michael
Gendler my lawyer for over I think it's
30 years isn't Michael something like
that I stay I stick with people until
they die Nancy Meyers and Charles Shire
Nora Ephron Frank Griffin my makeup man
for over how many 20 years more than
that more than that Dan Melnick a
producer who had a great eye for a
script fred skep see who directed
Roxanne John Hughes who wrote and
directed planes trains and automobiles
if I read the first script and it was
the first script was 165 pages long and
I I loved the script I said to John what
are you thinking about cutting and he
said cutting the first the first cut of
the film was four and a half hours long
Phil Robinson who is here tonight and
wrote all of me which absolutely changed
my career Brian Grazer another producer
who kept his eye on the script Ron
Howard David Mamet Larry Kasdan the
greater Larry Kasdan Frank Oz is here
tonight who did so much great great
comedies some of my best comedies with
him Mick Jackson who directed la story
John Landis who directed the little
movie that could three amigos Bob
Simon's ed LaMotte Oh God rest his soul
adam Vinit somebody in my agents have
died watch out Adam
my wife and Stringfield who is as
beautiful as she is smart and I knew I
wasn't going to make it through this
speech I read it to my dog this morning
in web
my wife alone would have been enough
reward for my life but now she has
brought me a wonderful child and for
some mysterious reason she really loves
that child I don't know I don't go in
2008 Nancy Meyers asked me to appear and
it's complicated with Meryl Streep and
Alec Baldwin I hadn't done a movie in a
long while and I didn't really know how
I felt about them anymore because along
with the joy that they have brought me
over the past 34 years people in this
room know they also bring an equal
amount of artistic heartache heartache
and I went out to the set across the
Queensboro Bridge on a cold winter
morning and on the first day of shooting
I opened the door to the dark soundstage
I stepped over all those blacks sneaking
electric cables and walked past the
craft service table that overflowed with
boxes of raisins and bagels and muffins
and the slowest toaster in the world
and jars of M&Ms and Twizzlers for
breakfast n every variety of mustard and
I as I made this little journey that I
had made a thousand times at every
studio in this city walking through the
corridors through this flimsy plywood
flats and the light changing from
pitch-black to blinding white
I thought home so to get an award for
something that you realize has seeped
into your bones and to understand
tonight that the work over the decades
has at least meant something to someone
is especially satisfying but working in
the movies has also brought something an
amazing gift that is accumulated through
these decades of filmmaking that cannot
be matched something wonderful and
magical and its impact on my life is
profound friends fascinating funny and
lifelong many of them are here in this
room tonight so thank you movies and
thank you Academy for this award and a
glorious reminder of the true benefit
that I have received